as i just mentioned there does seem to
be something more nefarious going on
here
like they they want you to lock yourself
down almost after more than two years of
a lot of people largely staying home to
the pandemic most americans were ready
to hit the road but according to a new
report by morning consult the inflation
and record-breaking gas prices are more
responsible for keeping folks from their
vacations this summer than coven here
now is newt gingrich former speaker of
the house fox news contributor author of
defeating big government socialism
newt
it's american as apple pie the idea of
hopping in your car
and just taking a summer road trip
whether you're single or whether you're
married you have kids that's part of the
american experience
that's being deteriorated right now
sure look at every aspect
of american life is being deteriorated
right now
one lady
was reported from washington
pennsylvania saying she has to go to
four or five stores to find baby formula
and she can't afford the gasoline to go
to four or five stores so these these
become compounding disasters
you have a rising crime rate you have
nutcake left-wing da's who won't keep
people locked up so the cities become
worse you have an administration and i
think the earlier conversation was
exactly right the the big difference was
not personality bill clinton made a
decision
in the fall of 1995
that in order to get reelected he would
sell out the left move to the center
sign welfare reform sign a balanced
budget do whatever it took because he
understood if he didn't change his
policies
words weren't going to work
these people can't change who they are
and they're in the middle of a disaster
it's going to get worse at every level
the governor of pennsylvania just signed
an executive order that will punish
western pennsylvania for producing
natural gas this is at a time by the way
when when the marcellus shale has 400
years supply
sitting right there in pennsylvania but
the governor can't get out of it because
his left would rather punish
pennsylvanians in the name of their
ideology
and i think you're going to see this
across the board i don't think they can
change and i think if they try to change
their party we'll have a civil war
and apparently new this is all extremely
hilarious to joe biden watch this
why aren't that right
record high today we're in a situation
where
you know because of a war
in uh in ukraine
gas prices and food prices are extremely
high the idea we're going to be able to
you know click a switch
bring down the cost of gasoline is not
likely in the near term nor is it with
regard to food
that's a winning message for the
midterms isn't it noon this morning in
america
m-o-u-r-n-i-n-g that's right look
look that this is a left-wing jimmy
carter i mean carter was incompetent but
he was sort of rational uh
biden is incompetent
and he's committed to a set of values
that are wrong
my guess is he's deep deep down he likes
higher gasoline prices it drives people
towards
some kind of new approach he doesn't
care about the price of food why are you
eating beef anyway uh you know you could
be a vegan everything would be less
expensive or you could have a victory
garden at home
he cares more about taking care of
illegal immigrants than he does about
taking care of americans and the result
is there the federal government was
competing for baby formula to take care
of illegal immigrants against americans
who couldn't find the baby formula so
you go down this list and it's it's not
a problem of performance it's a problem
of core
big government socialist values that are
antithetical
to the american future and to the
average american it's a it's a genuine
crisis of the system
newt i've said this before and i would
love your take on this to me it seems
the only way the democrat party might
reexamine
its priorities now its values right now
is it like a 1984 style wipeout in 2024
and a really significant wipeout in the
midterms it might not even take midterms
might not be enough it would have to be
a cataclysmic defeat for them in 2024
where new england states go maybe we get
some rocky mountain states uh for the
for the next presidential election your
thoughts on that
i think that's exactly right we're we
are
really in the fourth great wave reagan
and 80 was the first we were the second
in 1994. in 2010 in the house the
results were actually bigger than in 94.
john boehner's team got 64 seats we got
53. this is the fourth big wave in this
direction and again what happens is the
democrats go off the rails
the truth is that obama was as
anti-petroleum as anti-gasoline and
diesel fuel and heating oil as biden is
and it led to a rebellion
because people understood it
and i think what you're faced with now
the only hope for the american future to
return to sanity is a huge republican
victory this fall followed by a
republican party behaving like a genuine
reform party as we did and then followed
by a presidential election which is
cataclysmic for the democrats
at that point although remember it took
the
it took the republicans from 1932 into
the 1950s to finally come to grips with
the reality of fdr it could easily take
an entire generation
for the democrats to figure out they
can't be this crazy and expect to ever
win again new great to see you thanks so
much